Ron DeSantis gets pointed and
personal,
criticizing Donald Trump
on a wide array of issues
while trying to sell himself
at the same time to Trump voters
as better than the original.
It is an understatement
to call this new strategy risky,
but the Florida governor
is all in issuing
a statement this morning
with links
to 11 different Thursday interviews,
all of them
in the conservative echo chamber
in which
he has a long list of complaints
about the former president.
A big spender, he says,
not tough enough at the border.
He says friend of Fauci
to damage to win the White House again.
There's more.
As Governor,
DeSantis looks to use his first days
as an official candidate
to reset
both his campaign
and to reset the broader contours
of a Republican race.
The right now
is being run on Trump's turf.
It is a tight rope
no Republican has managed to walk before,
take on Trump
without earning
the ire of his loyal base.
This is how Governor Santos right here
hopes to keep his balance with Trump,
like promises to purge the deep state
and to look even at giving clean slates
to insurrectionists.
Do you think the January six defendants
deserve to have their cases
examined by a Republican
president on day one?
I will have folks that will get together
and look at all these cases
who people are victims of weaponization
or political targeting,
and we will be aggressive
in issuing parties.
Let's get straight to Miami.
CNN's Steve Van Tornoe is there.
Steve, it is an interesting
and a risky strategy
That's right, John.
I've been covering government instances
for the better part of the last decade.
I have heard him speak
probably more than 100 times.
I have never heard him go
after the former president
in such direct terms.
And keep in mind,
he was in Congress for two years
while Trump was a president.
He was a closely aligned governor
with Trump for two years as well.
And during that stretch,
he never really publicly
raised any sort of criticisms
with the Trump
presidency and said, in fact, he
he often cheered it on and he sought
and ran
on President Trump's endorsement
when he ran for governor in 2018.
But this change in strategy
is clearly designed to try to
to urge
some Republicans to get behind him
and to cast a Trump years
as not as great
as maybe some people remember it.
That's a risky bet.
As you said,
there are still a lot of Republicans
who look back on those past
four years fondly
even though they might be open
to a potential alternative in 2024.
The question is is DeSantis
pushing those people off the fence
toward him
or pushing them away from him
because he is being so critical
of someone
they still really, really like.
But DeSantis has got
a lot of money behind him.
He has raised over $8 million
in the first 24 hours since he was made,
since he jumped into the race.
And he is going to put that money
behind this message,
get out in front of as many voters
as possible.
And continue to make his case
to conservative media
that he is the best person
to lead this fight
and to take that take
and go into the White House
and use the presidency in a way
that Republicans
have been too scared to use it before.
John,
that's fascinating.
Beginning
of the official DeSantis campaign.
Steve Cohen, Total Force in Miami.
Steve, thank you for getting us started.
Let's bring the conversation in the room
with me to share their reporting
and their insights, CNN's Lauren Fox.
Dylan Young's of The New York Times
and Jackie Kucinich of The Boston Globe.
I call it a tightrope
The question is, is it different?
Is it different
now that Trump has been president
than it was in 2016
when Jeb Bush, Ted Cruz, Marco Rubio,
John Kasich,
Rand Paul, and so on and so forth said
Donald Trump's not a real conservative.
Donald Trump's not a good person.
Ron DeSantis saying he's
not a committed conservative.
He's damaged goods.
I can win. He can't.
Can you sell that?
Can you go that aggressively
after Donald Trump
and keep enough of the Trump voters
to win the Republican nomination?
That's what Ron DeSantis is banking on.
Whether he'll be successful
is something else entirely.
I mean, Trump has
and Trump is doing the same thing
he did during that race.
He's mocking him
he's coming right at him.
They you know,
they took advantage of the fact
that his initial launch
was less than desired.
Put it that way.
So I and you also DeSantis also
has a lot of competition for that lane.
And so it really
it kind of seems like
we're watching the same movie
honestly, where you're having, you know,
all these
other people
pulling the people
who don't want Trump back.
But we'll send the sands.
It hasn't really he's he's above them,
but he hasn't really, really
proved he can surmount Trump yet.
Right.
That that is the challenge yet again.
You know, how do you.
The dissenters
calculation is Trump's
going to get 30% of the vote
in most states maybe you'll get 35% here.
Can you peel away enough of that
in a crowded field.
Listen to one of the things
he's trying to say
because he knows he has to be careful.
Donald Trump essentially,
he says was great.
Not anymore.
I don't know
what happened to Donald Trump.
This is a different guy today
than when he was running in 20, 15
and 2016.
And I think
I think the direction
that he's going with
this campaign is the wrong direction.
You know,
again, trying to convince
Trump voters come to me,
I will be Trumpy
but I don't have the baggage,
I don't have the grievances,
I don't have the negativity.
Maybe I can win independents.
This is a difficult balancing act here.
You know, he's
not criticizing
the values
the policies of the former president,
but trying to criticize the candidate.
And I thought
my former colleague
Jonathan Martin
made a good point in his column today.
Basically,
saying that there is this sort of
risk here
when you criticize the former president,
particularly
since he has such a grip on the party
right now.
Do you come off as being
not a member of the GOP,
not one that is supportive of Trump
and the party, but more
so the other side,
somebody that actually is giving in to
Democrat s
and actually helping out
President Biden when you criticize
Donald Trump.
It's interesting to see him continued.
DeSantis continued to make these comments
trying to have a distinction
between the policies that Trump supported
and saying he
no longer is the best candidate
to continue to support them.
Pointed to things
such as the border, such as COVID.
But while DeSantis
continues to use language
that is so similar to that of before
and so you mentioned
the Jonathan Martin column in Politico.
Let me read a piece from a because it's
a smart column,
but he quotes David Kochel,
a very veteran Iowa
Republican strategist.
The conservative media
ecosystem has built
a giant wall of a knock inoculation
around everything Trump
all our voters have ever known
about Trump as he's
constantly under attack.
So he's got these antibodies
build up so long, Fox.
That's the question.
Can somebody like Ron DeSantis,
you know, when Chris Christie says this,
so John Kasich
says this or Jeb Bush says this.
Trump has already preprogramed
his base to not listen to those people.
He's disqualified them. Don't listen.
Ron DeSantis is one of them.
Or at least he wants them to believe he's
one of them. Can it?
Can a Trump take on Trump, I guess? Yeah.
I mean,
I think one of the
biggest questions is will Ron DeSantis
be successful at something
that everyone else who has been circling,
getting into the presidential race
or has already gotten into
the presidential
race has decided not to do?
He is really the first one
who is taking on Donald Trump
in such a direct way.
And in some ways, he had no other choice.
Right.
If Donald Trump is going to come after
you in the way
that Donald Trump came after him
right after announcing
perhaps he feels like
this is the moment to try.
But you raise such a good point,
which is that Donald Trump
and his supporters,
anyone who comes after them
they're just not conservative.
Well, Trump himself has been going
after DeSantis constantly.
And again,
if we could just show the picture
of the Republican presidential field,
you see the left side of the screen.
The candidates are already in the race.
You see on the right side
of your screen, candidates
who are considering the race.
Donald Trump has said
good things about Tim Scott.
He has said some nice things
about Vivek Ramos.
For me, for example,
he is attacking
Ron DeSantis constantly, several times
a day.
He goes after him.
He calls him a bad nickname.
Wrong, the sanctimonious.
We'll see if that sticks.
But Ron DeSantis yesterday
asked in those conservative interviews,
why do you think he's coming
after you and Ron
DeSantis says it's pretty obvious.
He understands
that I've got a good chance to beat him
because he doesn't criticize
anybody else. Now it's only me.
They know that I'm more likely
to win the election.
I mean, for him to say that
that we're not winning in Florida.
No.
Has taken the state
from being a swing state.
Four and a half years ago,
to now
being a red state
in such a dramatic fashion.
It is interesting to watch him it again.
He's speaking in the conservative
echo chamber.
You're speaking to people
many of whom
are inclined to support Donald Trump.
They essentially flipped a swipe,
a switch, as Steve was noting.
Up until then, he was gentle
in his criticism of Trump.
They've decided we're in now.
This is the only way
as Chris Christie says,
the only way to beat Trump
is to go through Trump. Yep, yep.
And it is
he is being attacked
because he is a threat.
I mean, that is very, very clear
that I think
I think the former president's people
have been pretty clear about that.
But the Sands is
DeSantis is going to have to
figure out a way to
make himself
distinctive and
not just be Trump lite, as Nikki Haley
said during one of her stops.
And if you look at our poll,
I just want to show right
now, Republican voters
do keep Trump and DeSantis
at the top of the pack.
Who are you open to voting for?
What supporter consider supporting Trump?
85, Trump.
84% to Sanders. 85%.
You see, the other two
are that six in ten or less there.
Here's the question
if DeSantis is going to daily
now repeatedly attack Trump
in the conservative ecosphere,
watch that number.
Does that number stay constant
or does it go down?
If it goes down, it's not working.
If it stays constant,
maybe there's an opening.